the oceans are the source of life we
depend on them for our very survival as
I think is increasingly well known now
every breath we take every drop of water
we drink connects us to the oceans and
if our if we allow this decline that is
continuing that has been accelerating
really and and since the Industrial
Revolution but especially in the last
decades to continue we will be left
without that life-support system it is
the blue heart of our planet and we are
all working together to try to promote
awareness among governments businesses
the private sector example Phi the
voices of NGOs have been working in this
field and also reach consumers as you
are there are steps that can be taken
and need to be taken by all of these
groups in order for us to succeed so
that I mean there's problems of
acidification of ocean warming of
overfishing and there's plastics I mean
all of those really resulting from human
activity of one kind or another that is
true that is true and it is changing the
nature of the oceans themselves the the
it is destroying marine ecosystems we've
lost half of the wildlife of the oceans
half of the coral reefs in the oceans we
have now 400 dead zones in the oceans
and of course we have the five massive
plastic tires of the oceans that are an
Akuma are plastic soup really that is
becoming more and more deadly to the
fish that know no borders the fish that
are polluted in in Europe or in Africa
or in the United States are making their
way in their annual migrations and could
end up on your plate or the plate of
anyone who eats seafood today I mean the
problem is you know plastic is cheap
lightweight durable how can we do
without it well there's a lot of
work going into that you have to address
the full lifecycle of plastics from sort
of oil extraction to their design and
packaging and to the end you know and
life of the plastics and a lot of tech
increasingly tech companies are looking
at this and you have businesses
beginning to look at how how they can
rethink redesign repackage move away
from single-use plastics into more you
know flexible and and and anyway this is
an example of an approach that consumer
can take businesses can take approaches
that begin with the beginning of the use
of their development of products and
governments really need to work on
plastic reduction policies as well
plastics in the country such as yours
which is not a coastal country I mean I
was going to say that the Middle East is
the other area I know about and in the
Middle East we have small a small
country for example that is the fourth
largest plastic bottle consumer in the
world and another one which is
considered after the United States to be
the largest plastic bag consumer these
are hard for me to believe these figures
because these are relatively small
countries but we have I think it is
30-something percent more than the world
average of plastic pollution in our
region so governments are starting as
many governments around the world have
come late to this but are starting to
approach you know look at non
biodegradable plastics as being and
looking at the production and requiring
the production of biodegradable bags
plastic bags for their interim I suppose
that's a good solution I think for the
for the long term one has to move away
from from that because still oil and
petroleum products are going into the
creation of every kind of plastic as I
understand it and I'm not an expert but
that is a serious problem for our part
of the world as well I mean in in the
question growth global warming to a
certain extent to get some movement on
that in the end it took
America and China to come together and
and and lead the world the last
Secretary of State John Kerry made
oceans very much part of his campaigning
deal was a communist
new administration kind of not so much
so can it be done without America well
the ocean elders among others are going
to work very hard to hold on to the
progress that's been made by the way to
UK by 2020 should have four kilometres
of four million kilometres of marine
protected areas that it oversees in its
in its overseas territories so that is a
very strong you know commitment on the
part of this government in the u.s. the
Arctic ban of you know President Obama's
ban on architect drilling the increase
of the marine protected monument around
Hawaii which I think is the largest in
the world and and other advances that
were made as well as on the
international level these are very
important and heartening bits of
progress but they are bits if you look
at the whole picture and we just have to
protect those and maintain the momentum
the the policymakers who insist on
looking at short term often I don't to
say it's always the case but profit over
the long term welfare and well-being of
their children and their children are
also not understanding that there are no
borders in the oceans there is no way
that you can build a gated community
that with all the wealth in the world
that will protect you from the effects
of the decline of ecosystems in the
oceans they also protect coastal areas
from from you know the effects of
hurricanes and massive storms as well as
being a source of food on on your plate
and also having an impact on the carbon
you know in the ocean is a carbon sink
so it has an impact on climate there's
one thing we could all do I thought this
program what would be consumers can do
what my family and I and so many
of you all are doing today which is we
can change our habits there are some
microplastics which we haven't had a
chance to talk about are such a foul
source of toxicity in our oceans in our
food as it comes to us from the oceans
and it isn't that difficult to find
alternatives to plastic bottles that are
so common today and our land-based
litter is the 80% of the litter that
ends up in the ocean it's come from land
and that's where we need to start in
terms of of looking at whether it's
cosmetics or or just the the articles
you use in your bathrooms and q-tips III
have organic q-tips now that don't have
the plastic handle because that's what I
grew up with the plastic handled once an
enormous amount of plastic that ends up
being consumed and then tossed and
inevitably ends up in our waters and in
our food and you know there are many
other ways you can actually even this is
probably pushing it a bit look into the
synthetics in your clothing and make
sure that you're trying to purchase
clothing that is as you know there is
has fewer of the types of plastics
incorporated into it that break down
every time you wash them in the washing
machine and end up in the water so there
are many different things it takes a
little bit of research but take the time
because it's worth it the impact that
collectively we can have can be pretty
phenomenal